Alright,
uh,
let's hope we can free our minds of these matters now and turn into something a
little more substantive,
uh,
which is,
the question,
uh,
before we plunge into God of her.
Really perhaps the question,
what is hermeneutics?
Uh,
well,
it's easily enough explained what it is despite the sort of difficulty in
thorniness of the word,
uh,
it is,
the art,
uh,
or,
principles of interpretation.
Um,
but hermeneutics has a history that is to say it's not something which has
always been just there.
It's not something that people have always thought about in a systematic way.
Strictly speaking,
what I've just said isn't true.
Uh,
many of you probably know that Aristotle has a treatise called day interpret.
[inaudible].
Um,
the Middle Ages are rife with,
uh,
with,
treatises on interpretation and suppose wa I suppose what I'm really saying is
that the word hermeneutics wasn't available.
And the idea that there ought to be a sort of a systematic study of how we
interpret things,
um,
wasn't really,
uh,
current.
Um,
but so,
and of course,
by the same token,
um,
uh,
the,
the notion of hermeneutics arises primarily,
uh,
in religion first,
in and,
and specifically in the Christian tradition.
But that isn't to say that there hasn't been,
that,
there wasn't long before the moment at which hermeneutics became important at
Christianity.
Uh,
that's not to say that there wasn't a century's worth of towel.
Moody's Scholarship,
uh,
which is essentially also hermaneutic in nature.
That is to say,
concerned with the art and basis of interpretation.
But what gave rise to in,
in the Western world to what is called Hermeneutics was in fact,
uh,
the Protestant reformation.
And there's a lot of significance of that in,
in that I think,
and I'll try to explain why you don't really puzzle your head about questions of
interpretation,
how we interpret validity of interpretation and so on until a meaning becomes
terribly important to you and be the ascertainment of meaning becomes difficult.
And you say to yourself,
well,
isn't it always the case that meaning is important?
And that meaning is hard to construe?
Well,
not necessarily.
You know,
if,
uh,
you are a person whose sacred scripture is adjudicated by the pope and the
occasional tribunal of church elders,
you yourself don't really need to worry very much about what scripture means.
You're told what it means.
It goes without saying,
therefore what it means.
But in the wake of the Protestant reformation,
when the question of one's relationship with the Bible became personal and
everyone was aunt was understood if only through the local minister to be a and
gauged with coming to an understanding of what is after all a pretty difficult,
who on Earth knows what the parables mean and so on and the,
and,
and the whole of the Bible,
uh,
poses interpretive difficulties.
Then of course your going to have to start worrying about how to interpret it.
And needless to say,
since it's a sacred scripture,
the meaning of it is important to you.
You do want to know what it means.
It can't mean just anything.
It's crucial to you to know exactly what it means and why what it means is
important.
And so as Protestantism took hold,
by the same token,
the art and the arts and sciences of Hermeneutics took hold and people began to
write treatises about interpretation,
but it was always interpretation of the Bible.
In other words,
in this tradition,
religion came first after that,
the next thing that happens is you begin to get the rise of constitutional
democracies.
And as you get that,
you begin to be become much more interested as a citizen or as a person who has
suffrage or as a person in one way or another,
um,
has the,
uh,
has,
has the rights of the state or nation it may get you begin to become concerned
about the nature of the laws you live under.
And that's why hermeneutics gradually moved,
not deserted religion,
but so I should say expanded to the study of the law and the arts and sciences
that had been developed in thinking about interpreting scripture were then
applied to the interpretation of something the meaning of which had become
almost as important as to say it mattered what the law was and how it was to be
interpreted.
And you know,
of course,
that this is absolutely crucial to the study of the law to this day.
You know,
what are the grounds for understanding the meaning of the constitution,
for example.
Uh,
there are widespread controversies about it and many of the courses you would
take in law school are meant to try to get to the bottom of these thorny
questions.
Well,
uh,
well and good.
Once again,
you see that hermeneutics enters a field when the meaning of something becomes
more important and when,
uh,
that meaning is recognized to be difficult to grasp.
Now as yet,
you know,
we haven't said anything about literature and the fact is there is no art of,
uh,
no hermaneutic art devoted to literature during the early modern period and for
most of the 18th century,
uh,
think about,
you know,
the writers you've studied from the 18th century.
It's very interesting that they all just sort of take beaning for granted.
Uh,
if,
if you think about pope,
for example,
or even Johnson as they reflect on literature and why it's important and what
the nature of literature is,
they don't,
they aren't concerned about interpretation.
They're concerned about evaluation,
establishing the principles of,
of,
of what,
uh,
of what's at stake in writing a poem or in writing literature in some other
form,
um,
uh,
and,
and raise questions that are largely,
uh,
moral,
and,
and aesthetic.
They're not concerned about interpretation because to them,
good writing is precisely writing that's clear writing that doesn't need to be
interpreted but has as precisely as it's virtue.
It's transparency of meaning.
And in fact,
during this whole period,
um,
playwrights were writing prologues to their place,
abusing for each other,
for being obscure.
That is to say abusing each other for requiring interpretation.
I don't understand what your metaphors are all about.
You don't know what a metaphor is.
All you do is make one is,
is make one verbal mistake after another.
Nobody can understand you.
This is the nature of the prose and verse prefaces to a theatrical pieces in the
18th century.
And from that you can see that interpretation is not only not study,
but it's considered to be completely extraneous to what's valuable about
literature.
If you have to interpret it,
it isn't any good.
But then as the 18th century wears on,
you begin to get the sense in the first place.
You get a,
as,
as with the emergence of romanticism,
you got to kind of as,
as as well known and I think often overstated,
uh,
you'll get a cult of genius.
Uh,
you get the idea,
uh,
that everything arises from the extraordinary,
mental acuity or spiritual insight of an author.
And that knew what needs to be understood about literature is the genius of its
production.
Well,
well and good.
But at the same time,
if that's the case and if there's this extraordinary emphasis on the importance
of the expression of genius,
you can see what's beginning to happen.
The literary creators starts to seem a lot more like the divine creator.
That is to say,
uh,
and,
and in a certain sense could be understood as a place holder for the divine
creator.
Remember that,
uh,
secularization,
in western culture is increasing during the course of the enlightenment.
That is to say during the course of the 18th century.
And there's a certain way in which romanticism and in what,
what's important about romanticism can be understood as what Northrop Frye has
called a secular scripture.
In other words,
the meaning of literature becomes more difficult because it's profoundly
subjective and no longer,
uh,
some and no longer engaged with shared values.
Uh,
and the importance of literature.
That is to say our sense of why it's so important to understand.
It has also grown because for many people it begins to take over partly at least
the role of religion.
And so with the rise of secular a scripture that is to say literature imagined
as something both terribly important and also difficult to understand naturally
the arts and sciences of Hermeneutics,
hermeneutics begin to enter that field.
And in particular,
the great theologian of the Romantic period,
Friedrich Schleiermacher devoted his career to,
uh,
principles of hermeneutics that were meant to be applied as much to literature
as to the study of scripture,
uh,
and established a tradition in which it was understood that literature was a
central focus of hermeneutics.
So that's then for the history of,
of Hermeneutics,
the,
uh,
the work of,
of,
of dill tire on the turn of the century of Heidegger in his being in time 1927
of God Umer,
who in many ways,
uh,
can be understood as a disciple and student of Heidegger.
Uh,
and the,
and a tradition which presents today,
um,
follows from the initial engagements of Schleiermacher during the romantic
period with literature.
All right,
so what is the basic problematic for hermeneutics in this tradition?
It's what we probably all have heard about.
Um,
and something that I will briefly try to describe what's called the hermaneutic
circle.
So what is the hermaneutic circle?
It's a relationship between a reader,
add a text,
or in the case of certain kinds of students of Hermeneutics,
but not gone.
I'm,
or I think of a relationship between a reader and an author.
In other words,
a relationship which is,
which is,
which is understood to aim at understanding the intention of an author,
the author of the forth quotation on your sheet today,
ed Hirsch belongs in that tradition,
who understands the hermaneutic circle as a relationship between a reader and an
author where the text is a kind of immediate Tory document containing the
meaning of the author but forgot him or,
and his tradition.
It's a little different.
It can be understood as the relationship between a reader and a text.
And this can be put in a variety of ways.
Uh,
it's often put in terms of the relationship between the part and the whole.
I approached a text,
um,
and of course the first thing I read is a phrase or sentence.
There's still a lot more of the text.
And so that's,
that's a part.
But I immediately began to form an opinion about this heart,
this part with respect to an imagined or supposed hole.
And then,
you know,
I,
and I use the sense I have of what the whole must be like to continue to read
successive parts.
What is,
what success is.
This was excessive parts,
lines,
uh,
sentences,
whatever they may be.
And I keep referring those successive parts back to a sense of the whole which
changes as a result of knowing more and more and more parts.
And so the circularity of this interpretive engagement has to do with moving
back and forth between a certain preconception about the hole that I form from
studying apart,
moving then to the part back to the whole,
back to the part,
back to the whole and so on,
in a circular pattern.
This can also be understood as the relationship between the present and the
past.
That is to say my particular historical horizon,
uh,
and some other historicals horizon that I'm trying to come to terms with.
Uh,
so that I refer back and forth to,
to what I know about the world before I engage the tax.
Uh,
what the text's seems to scene seems to be saying in relation to that,
which I know how it might change my sense of what I know.
Ah,
but referring back from what I know,
uh,
continuously to an understanding of the way in which the past text speaks.
And finally,
of course,
because hermeneutics isn't just something that takes place across and historical
golf,
it also can take place across a social or cultural golf,
maybe not even very much of a Gulf.
When we engage each other in conversation,
we are still performing our hermaneutic act.
I have to try to understand what you're saying and I have to refer it to what I
want to say.
And the circuit of communication between us has to stay open as a result of this
mutual and developing understanding of what we're talking about.
Uh,
and it's the same thing of course with conversations across cultures.
So understand that hermeneutics isn't necessarily about as as God him or would
put it merging historical horizons.
It's also about merging social and cultural and interpersonal horizons and it,
and it applies to all of those spheres.
All right?
Now the hermeneutic circle then is,
uh,
of this is sort of involves this reference back and forth between the entities
that I've been trying to describe.
And let's just quickly uh,
and here we begin to move into the tax.
Let's let us up.
Uh,
listen to God Homer's version of how the circularity of this thinking works on
paid seven 22 toward the bottom of the left hand column.
The reader got hammers where it is he the reader projects before himself a
meaning for the text as a whole,
as soon as some initial meaning emerges in the text.
In other words,
as soon as he sees what the part is like he projects or imagine what the whole
must be that contains this part again the ladder.
That is to say the,
the sense of the initial meaning emerges only because he is reading the text
with particular expectations in regard to a certain meaning.
The working out of this four project,
that is to say the sense we have in advance of the meaning of what we are going
to read the working out of this four project which is constantly revised in
terms of what emerges as he penetrates into the meaning is understood as what is
there.
In other words,
God,
that what is there,
which is a kind of way of talking that got them or inherits from Heidegger,
uh,
really has to do with what got them or means when he talks also about dissoc the
subject matter.
In other words,
they effort of a reader and coming to terms with the meaning of a text is an
effort to master the subject matter.
What is there.
Uh,
and I suppose it's fair enough to say,
uh,
it as a kind of paraphrase what the text is really about.
I mean that that's what got him or means when he says what is there anyway,
you can say that in this passage on page seven 22,
God is describing the circularity of our reading and he's describing it in a way
that may raise certain concerns for us.
What do you mean a four structure or a four project?
Uh,
for having cat?
I view this thing as we might say objectively.
In other words,
aren't I going to be hopelessly prejudiced about what I read?
If I've got some sort of preliminary conception of what it's all about?
Why don't I just set aside my pro preliminary conceptions so that I can
understand precisely what is there,
how am I ever going to understand what is there if I approached,
if I,
if I approach it with some sort of preliminary idea,
which I never really get rid of.
I mean because each revision of what I think is there as a result of further
reading is nevertheless becomes in itself yet another four project or
preliminary conception.
In other words,
this way of thinking seems to suggest to tell you the truth does suggest that
you can't get away from preliminary conceptions about things and this of course
is disturbing and it's,
and it's especially disturbing when you then get Heidegger and god him or
insisting that even though there are always these preliminary conceptions which
got them or sort of boldly calls,
prejudices,
and we'll come back to that even though there are always these preliminary
conceptions,
there nevertheless are as Heidegger puts it two ways into the circle,
right?
A circle in other words is not necessarily a vicious circle.
See,
that's what you're attempted to conclude.
If you say,
I can never get away from preconceptions,
right?
It's just I'm just going back and forth meaninglessly because I'm never going to
get anyplace.
Right?
Um,
but God ever and Heidegger say,
no,
that's not true.
That's not true.
Circle isn't at all necessarily vicious.
The way into the circle can also be constructive.
That is to say you really can get someplace.
And so you're entitled to say,
well,
okay,
it can be constructive,
but how can that be?
Take a look at the second passage on your sheet from Heidegger,
not the whole passage,
but just the first sentence of it where Heidegger says,
in an interpretation,
the way in which the entity we are interpreting is to be conceived,
can be drawn from the entity itself,
or the interpretation can force the entity into concepts to which it is opposed
in its manner of being.
Now,
wait a minute.
You say,
if I'm just dealing in preconceptions here,
how can I take anything from the entity itself?
Right?
That's just what seems to be a at risk.
Uh,
if I can never get beyond my preconceptions,
well,
let me give you an example.
I was going to do this later in the lecture,
but I feel like doing it now.
Um,
in the,
in the 18th century,
uh,
a port named Mark Akin side wrote a long poem,
the pleasures of the imagination.
And in this poem there's the line,
the great creator raised his plastic arm.
Now let's say that we are of course we're into polymers.
We know what plastic is.
We have no,
we have no concern or hesitation and insane what,
what plastic is.
And so we say,
Oh gee,
well I guess the create great Creator has a sort of a prosthetic limb.
Um,
and uh,
and he raised it all right.
So that's,
that's,
that's what the sentence must mean.
Um,
but then of course if we know something about the horizon within which ache
inside was riding his poem,
we are aware that in the 18th century,
the word plastic men send us powerful,
flexible.
And in that case,
of course,
we immediately are able to recognize what ache inside men,
why it makes perfect sense.
Great,
great creator raised his sinuous powerful,
flexible arm.
Um,
and we know where we stand.
Now notice this there.
In other words,
this is an example of good and bad prejudice,
right?
The good prejudice is our prior awareness.
That plastic meant something different in the 18th century that it means now.
And we bring that prejudice to bear on our interpretation of the line,
and that is a constructive way into the circle according to Heidegger and got
him.
Or the bad prejudice is when we leap to the conclusion without thinking for a
moment that there might be some other historical horizon that we know what
plastic means.
And the reason we can tell the difference by the way,
is that if we invoke the 18th century meaning of plastic,
we immediately see that the line makes perfect sense,
that it's perfectly reasonable and not even particularly notable or,
and if we,
but if we bring our own meaning to bear,
that is to say our own sense of what the word plastic means,
then of course the meaning of the line must be crazy.
I mean,
what on earth do you know why?
Why would he be saying this about the great creator?
Now,
I think I'll come back to this example next week when we're talking about an
essay called the intentional fallacy by wk website.
And I will revisit the possibility that there might be some value in supposing
that ache inside meant,
uh,
the great creator raised his prosthetic limb.
But I'll leave that,
but I'll leave that until next week.
I think for the moment it should be playing to you that this is a good example
or a good way of understanding what the difference between a useful
preconception and a useless preconception brought to bear on an interpretive act
might consistent all right now and giving the example.
Now I've gotten a little bit,
uh,
ahead of myself.
Uh,
but so,
so let me reprise a bit.
As you can tell from your reading of God's word and of course the title of the
Great Book from which this excerpt is taking his truth and method bar height may
toda with its implicit suggestion that there is a difference between truth and
method.
Uh,
the great objection of God and her two other people's way of doing hermeneutics
is that they believe that there is a methodology of interpretation and the basic
methodology God him or is attacking in the excerpt you've read is what he calls
historicism.
Now that's a tricky word for us because later in the semester we're going to be
reading about something called the new historicism and the new historicism
actually has nothing to do with what God or is objecting to in this form of
historicism.
So we will return to the newest stores and that contact was it for the moment,
what God remains by historicism.
Is this the belief that you can set aside preconception,
in other words,
that you can completely factor out your own subjectivity,
your own view of things,
your own historically conditioned point of view.
I'm sorry,
I shouldn't have said historically condition your own point of view.
You can completely factor that out in order to enter into the mindset of some
other time or place that you can completely enter into the mind of another.
This then is the op.
This is the object of historicizing.
Um,
and as we'll see at the end of the lecture,
uh,
there's a certain nobility about it to be juxtaposed with the nobility of God
Omarion hermeneutics.
But in the meantime,
God has objected to this because he says,
you simply can't do this.
You cannot factor out these preconceptions.
All you can do,
he says,
is recognize that you do exist.
You do live.
You do think consciously within a certain horizon,
recognize that you are coming face to face with another horizon and tried to
bridge your horizon and the other horizon.
In other words,
to put it simply defined,
common ground to find some way of merging a present with a past a here,
whether they're in such a way that results in what God him or calls Hori Hori
taunts Farish Nelson,
horizon merger,
uh,
and this and this act of horizon merger,
has as its effect,
uh,
as its result,
what God ever calls effective history.
And by effective history,
he means history,
which is useful.
That is to say history,
which really can go to work for us and is not just a matter of accumulating an
archive or distancing ourselves from the past.
Uh,
I'll say again,
somewhat in advanced perhaps of the time I should say it,
that God them or thinks that there's something immoral about historicism.
Why?
Because it condescends toward the past.
It's supposes that the past is simply a repository of information and it never
suppose for a minute that if we actually merge ourselves with the moment of the
past,
the past may be able to tell us something we ought to know.
That is to say,
may be able,
uh,
actually to teach us something God him or believes that historicism for gets the
possibility of being taught something by passiveness or otherness.
Now,
I think in order to make this,
this viewpoint seem plausible,
we probably should study it for a moment a little bit more philosophically.
That is to say,
uh,
you're asking yourself,
well,
sure,
you know what?
I can,
and I,
I pride myself on this.
I can factor out all forms of subjectivity.
I really can be objective.
I'm perfectly capable of understanding the past in and for itself without any
contribution of my own,
without in short any preconceptions.
So let's look at a couple of facet just from your sheet,
uh,
from Heidegger's being in time from his analytic of the hermeneutic circle.
Um,
and see what Heidegger has to say about this claim.
The first passage on your sheet,
Heidegger says,
when we have to do with anything,
the mirror scene of the things which are closest to us,
bears and itself,
the structure of interpretation and in so primordial a manner that just to grasp
something free as it were of the Az requires a certain adjustment.
What does Heidegger Sang?
He Sang,
I stand here and I,
and I'm just looking on just,
I look back there and I,
I,
I'm just seeing that sign that says exit.
I'm not interpreting it.
I don't have any preconception about it.
I'm just looking right?
Heidegger says,
this is a total illusion.
How do I know it's a sign?
How do I know it says exit?
How do I mean?
I bring a million preconceptions to bear on what I take to be a simple act of
looking and then the girl says,
you know what?
It's not an all an interesting to imagine the possibility of just seeing
something without seeing it as something.
It would be kind of exhilarating wouldn't it,
to be able just to have something before us.
Right,
but he says,
you know what,
that is well nigh impossible.
It is in fact a very,
very difficult and derivative act of the mind to try to forget that.
I'm looking at a sign that says exit and in fact just to be looking at what is
there without knowing.
In other words,
I don't not know first that that's a sign that says exit.
The very first thing I know is that it's a sign that says exit.
There is no prior act of consciousness.
It's the very first thing that I know.
It's an interesting thought experiment to try not to know that that's a sign
that says exit and as of your points out in this passage,
that's a thought experiment,
which if it can be done at all derives from that prior knowledge.
I always know something first as something if I can just have it there before
me.
That is a very difficult and derivative intellectual act and it cannot be
understood as primordial or primitive.
You know,
I am always already in possession of an interpretation of whatever object I look
at,
which isn't at all to say that my interpretation is correct.
It's only to say that I can't escape the fact that the very first movement of
mine,
not the last movement,
but the first movement of mine is interpreted.
All right.
We always see something as something and that is precisely the act of
interpretation.
We can never just have it there before us or as I say if we can,
if we can.
It's a very,
very difficult act.
Continue the passage,
this grasping,
which as which is free of the,
as is a privation of the kind of seeing and you see how attracted Heidegger is
to it because he shifts his rhetoric is a privation of the kind of seeing in
which one merely understands.
And other words it would be an extraordinary thing not to understand.
Heidegger is saying we can't help understanding.
We always already understand,
which has nothing to do.
Again with whether or not we're right or wrong,
we always already just necessarily do understand.
It's a kind of imprisonment understanding and I,
and when Heidegger says,
wouldn't it be great not to have to merely understand,
right?
He's saying,
wouldn't it be great just to have it there before us,
but he's also insisting that this is an incredibly difficult,
if not impossible moment of thought.
All right?
So
that's why this is,
this is perhaps the essential,
the central passage and you,
and I don't want to pause over it,
but you can look at passage number three on your sheet,
which says roughly again what Heidegger is saying and the first passage.
That's why,
uh,
we must work always as interpreters with preconceptions,
with four understandings.
Now what about this word prejudice?
It is a sort of a problematic word.
Uh,
God,
her is a bit apologetic about it and he goes into the appropriate etymologies.
You know,
the French praise Uj the German for or tile all mean prejudgment,
uh,
a prior judgment,
and they actually can be used in a court of law as a stage toward arriving at a
verdict.
Um,
they need to be accompanied by popular prejudice against prejudice as gardener
says,
this is the characteristic.
Uh,
this is the characteristic idea of the enlightenment.
It's prejudice against prejudice that we can be objective,
that we can free ourselves of press.
Okay,
fine.
But,
uh,
you know,
prejudice is bad.
You know,
we have,
we have it right to do.
I mean,
we know prejudice is bad.
We know,
uh,
we know what prejudice has ra historically and socially.
So how so,
how can we try to vindicate it in this way?
It's,
it's extremely problematic.
What got them or does in his essay is actually,
uh,
an active intellectual conservatism.
It has to be admitted.
That whole section of the essay in which he talks about classicism and you may
have said to yourself as you were reading it,
well gee,
isn't this sort of digressive what's he,
what's he so interested in classicism for the whole section of the essay which
he's talking about classicism and which he,
which he later calls tradition is meant to suggest that we really can't merge
horizons effectively unless we have a very broad and extensive common ground
with what we're reading.
And the great thing about classicism forgot them or,
or what he calls tradition is that it's something we can share the classical got
him or argues is that,
which doesn't just speak to its own historical moment but speaks for all time,
speaks to all of us in different ways but does speak to us.
That is to say does proffer its claim to speak true.
They're classical can do that.
Okay Great.
We say it had gotten over that and and certainly your,
you're entitled to an intellectually conservative Canon.
Maybe other principles of hermeneutics.
We'll place much more stress on innovation or novelty or difference.
But you know,
you're a little,
you're,
you're not sure people can understand unless they share a great deal of common
ground all well and good.
But you know what,
that's where the bad side of prejudice sneaks in.
You know,
slavery,
um,
was considered perfectly appropriate and natural to the,
to a great many of the most exalted figures working within the tradition that
God,
I'm are rightly calls classical classical antiquity,
a great many modern figures never stopped to question slavery.
Slavery was eight was an aspect of classical culture which had its defenses.
Well God or it doesn't talk about this obviously,
but it is an aspect of that prejudice that one might share with tradition if one
worked somewhat more critical than this gesture of sharing might indicate.
I just say that in passing,
um,
uh,
calling your attention to it as a risk that's involved in our engagement with a
hermaneutic project,
uh,
of the nature of God hammers.
Uh,
and it's,
it's not to say the God and her favorite slavery or anything of the sort.
It is,
however,
to say that prejudice,
while plainly we can understand it simply to mean preconception,
which is inescapable and understand that philosophically,
nevertheless,
can still be bad.
And we have to,
and,
and we have to understand,
uh,
the way in which it's something that if we're going to accept this point of view
we need to live with all right now.
So it is troublesome.
It is troublesome and it's,
it's,
it's troublesome.
Uh,
also perhaps,
uh,
in a variety of other ways that I won't go into.
I think that what I'd like to do in the time remaining is to call your attention
to two passages.
One in God hammers text,
which I'm about to read.
And the other,
the fourth passage on your sheet by a,
uh,
by someone called Ed Hirsch,
whom you may actually know as the author of a dictionary of what every school
child should know,
uh,
and as a an and as a sort of a champion of the intellectual right during the
whole period when,
uh,
literary theory flourished.
But a person who also is seriously invested in Hermeneutics,
uh,
and,
and conducted a lifelong feud with God or,
uh,
about the principles of hermeneutics.
And the two passages that I'm about to read,
um,
juxtapose the viewpoints that I've been trying to evoke,
uh,
in describing got him or his position,
the dignity and nobility of God gardener is that it involves being interested in
what it in something true that is to say and hoping that there is an intimate
relationship between meaning arriving at meaning and arriving at something that
speaks to us as true.
Hirsch on the other hand,
is invoking a completely different kind of dignity.
And what I want you to realize as we juxtapose these two passages is that it is
impossible to reconcile them.
Uh,
and it poses for us a choice which as people interested in interpretation,
uh,
needs ultimately to be made and suggests perhaps differing forms of commitment.
Now,
the first passage is in God amorous text on page seven 35,
very bottom of the page.
And then I'll be going over to page seven 36
God ever says.
And here again,
he's attacking historicism.
The texts that is understood historically is forced to abandon its claim.
That it is uttering something true.
We think we understand when we see the past from a historical standpoint,
I e place ourselves in the historical situation and seek to reconstruct the
historical horizon.
I've been attempting to summarize this position.
And so I trust that I trust that it's easily intelligible as,
as I read it to you now.
In fact,
however,
we have given up the claim to find in the past any truth valid and intelligible
for ourselves.
And by the way,
this would also apply to cultural conversation.
You know,
I mean,
if I'm proud of knowing that in another culture,
if I Belch after dinner,
it's a compliment to the cook.
Right.
And if I'm proud of knowing that without,
you know,
without drawing any conclusions from it,
that's sort of the equivalent of historicism.
It's just a factoid for me.
In other words,
it's not,
you know,
it's not an effort to come to terms with anything.
It's not,
it's not an an effort to engage in dialogue.
It's just historicizing otherness.
In a way that some or other satisfies my quest for information.
That's what's so,
so it's not just a question of the past,
as I say,
and as I've said before,
it's a question of cultural conversation,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
thus this acknowledgement of the otherness of the other which makes him the
object of objective knowledge involves the fundamental suspension of his claim
to truth.
Devastating,
I think.
Brilliant argument and I think ought to remind us of what's at stake when we
invoke the notion of objectivity implicit according to gardener and the notion
of objectivity is an abandonment of the possibility of learning from the object
of learning from otherness.
It all,
it becomes a question of knowing the object of knowing it in and for itself in
its own terms and not at all necessarily of learning from it,
of being spoken to by it.
All right.
But now listen to Hirsch,
right?
This is,
you know,
I mean it's,
this is really,
this is really a hard choice to make.
What her says,
invoking con rightly invoking con,
he says,
con held it to be a foundation of moral action that men should be conceived as
ends in themselves,
not as instruments of other men and other words.
You are an end and not a means to me,
unless in fact I'm exploiting you and instrumentalizing you.
Right?
That's cons position and that's what hers is leaping to defend.
You know this idea,
you know that it that I don't really care or that I don't really think I can
come to terms with the actual sort of with,
with the actual meaning of an entity as that entity is instrumentalizing the
entity and other,
it's,
it's approaching it for me.
This,
this,
this turns the whole idea of being open to the possibility that the other is
speaking true.
Excuse me.
It turns that on its ear and says,
oh,
no,
you're just appropriating the other for yourself.
Right?
You're instrumentalizing the other.
You're not taking it seriously as itself.
That's what,
that's,
that's Hirsch's response and he continues.
This imperative is transferable to the words of men,
because speech is an extension and expression of men in the social domain.
And also because when we fail to conjoin a man's intention to his words,
we lose the soul of speech,
which is to convey meaning and to understand what is intended to be conveyed.
Notice that although the nobility of this alongside the nobility of gardener is
obvious and painful and really does seem to see to bring us to a crossroads,
you know where we really want to be Yogi Berra,
right?
And Go in both directions.
You know,
even though this is the case,
notice one thing,
hers is not saying anything about truth,
right?
He's talking about meaning.
That's good.
And he's,
and he,
and he's making the notion of arriving at a correct meaning as honorific as he
possibly can,
but it's insignificant,
but he's not talking about truth.
It's got them,
or who's talking about truth for her.
So the important thing is the meaning for God.
The important thing is that the meaning be true,
right?
And that's,
and that's where the,
that's where the distinction essentially lies.
God of are as willing to sacrifice because of his belief in the,
in the,
in escape ability of preconception is willing to sacrifice historical or
cultural exactitude of meaning.
He's willing to acknowledge that there's always something of me in my
interpretation,
but it's a good something because after all,
I am mindful of,
of the horizon of otherness.
I'm not just saying plastic means polymer,
right?
But nevertheless,
this something of me in the interpretation,
Hirsch is saying there's nothing of me and the interpretation.
Therefore I am able to arrive accurately and objectively at the meaning of the
other.
And I honor the other by arriving with such accuracy at the meeting.
But notice the tooth is bracketed out.
I mean,
it's not,
it doesn't seem to be a question for Hershey of whether the other speaks true.
This is unfair to her,
by the way,
because it actually is all you do.
All you need to do is read him and you will recognize that it does matter to
Hirsch whether the other speaks true,
but it's not implicit in the philosophical position.
He's taking up here.
It's something that the philosophical position sacrifices.
Okay.
So that's the basic distinction.
And as I say,
as far as I can see,
it's irreconcilable.
So you know,
it leaves us with a choice that really does have to be made and it's a choice
which looms over a course in literary theory and coming to understand the
tradition of literary theory.
So I'm,
we'll take one side,
others will take another and we'll find ourselves a siding or not siding with
them,
at least in part for reasons that arise out of the distinction between these two
positions that I've been making today.
Okay?
So we may or may not have the lecture on Eser,
but on Tuesday we'll be getting into the varieties of formalism.
And first we'll take up the American new criticism.
All right.
Thanks.